hey guys tim ferriss here before we jump
into this episode I'm gonna do something
I very rarely do and that is to make a
direct ask with hat in hand my brand new
book just came out today it is called
tribe of mentors subtitle short life
advice from the best in the world
if you like the podcast you will love
this book
I reached out to 130 people who are the
best at what they do in sports investing
business acting directing you name it we
got it cryptocurrency done and it turned
out better than I ever could have
expected many of my friends think of all
my books it is the easiest to read the
easiest to use so check it out please
take a look I put out so much free
material the podcast is free the
700-plus blog posts are free every once
in a while I put out something like this
and it's not that expensive so please
take a look tribe of mentors dot-com and
it does make a great holiday gift or
gift for others there's something for
everybody in here it is really a
choose-your-own-adventure guide a buffet
of options for improving your life both
in business and in the personal sphere
so take a look I appreciate you taking a
look tribe of mentors calm or anywhere
the books are sold at this altitude
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking
I must hypothetic organisms living
tissue over metal endoskeleton this
episode is brought to you by me undies
I've spent the last few years wearing
underwear from these guys 24/7 or close
to it outside of showers and sexy time
in swimming and they are the most
comfortable and colorful underwear I've
ever owned you should check out the
camouflage boxer briefs I'm a big fan me
undies are designed in LA and made from
sustainably sourced micro mowed ow
what's that it is a fabric three times
softer than cotton trust me try it out
you'll understand why I wear these so
much
if underwear isn't your thing though I
would imagine everyone wears underwear
but if it isn't your thing munities also
makes socks their socks are spun from
premium material making them just as
comfortable as the underwear now right
now the undies has an exclusive offer
just for tim ferriss show listeners you
can get 20% off your first order and
free shipping so check it out take a
look some of them are pretty rad they
have different cereals from your
childhood on underwear and a lot more me
undies com forward slash Tim take a look
my undies comm forward slash Tim they
offer a 100% satisfaction guarantee if
you're unhappy with your purchase for
any reason just send them back and you
receive a full refund again that's me
undies dot-com forward slash Tim for 20%
off and free shipping
this episode is brought to you by fresh
books man oh man do a lot of listeners
of this podcast and readers of mine love
fresh books to the extent that I ended
up meeting with the CEO not very long
ago why are they so popular well they
are the number one cloud accounting
software designed exclusively for
self-employed professionals that's many
of you and used by more than 10 million
people you can send invoices track your
time and get paid very very quickly
which suits the needs of a lot of
freelancers a lot of entrepreneurs and
beyond you can take pictures of receipts
you can link your credit card and debit
cards so all the things you buy
automatically appear in your fresh books
in the right category so on and so forth
makes taxes easy makes invoices easy
makes your life easier and also in fact
I'd recommend a PDF they didn't ask me
to read this part by the way they put
together PDF a while back called
breaking the time barrier subtitle how
to unlock your true earning potential so
you can search for breaking the time
barrier a lot of people ask me how can I
get a 4-hour workweek with a service
business and the story in that ebook its
PDF is the short answer it's really
really good so I think you should also
check that out so breaking the time
error check it out but also why not test
out fresh books claim your 30-day
unrestricted free trial at fresh
ebooks.com forward slash tim and enter
tim ferriss two hours in two S's in the
how did you hear about us section that
sounds like we're gonna get very little
tracking that's a lot of work but just
go to fresh books calm forward-slash tim
and try it out because it is a very good
product and i think you will find it
simplifies your life
enjoy
hello my sexy looking munchkins this is
Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show I'm
sitting in a freezing cold house with an
overdose of long tea and the unnamed
crazy Bulgarian who's back to his antics
to help me with book launch sama life
ski I have no idea what that means
but he's fun to have around like mini-me
alright the next episode that you are
gonna listen to you was recorded live in
the City of Angels Los Angeles in front
of a sold-out audience of around 2,000
people at summit LA 17 you can check out
what some it's all about at summit dot
co and you can find links to everything
all the show notes all the good stuff
from this conversation which is freaking
hilarious it's quite a roller coaster
with Brian Grazer at tuned up log
forward slash podcast so you can find
all the links all the goodies favorite
books all this stuff from every episode
at Tim da blog forward slash podcast and
if you haven't checked it out take a
look at the latest crazy project that is
launching right now tribe of mentors
calm that is my new tome tribe of
mentors calm and you can see sample
chapters the full list of mentors from
every possible discipline you can
imagine you're always asking how do I
find a mentor from the average of the
five people I associate with most how do
I learn from them this is how tribe of
mentors calm take a look so without
further ado as I like to say before I
talk even more please enjoy this
conversation with the incredible the
entertaining and ever so effective Brian
Grazer
how's everybody doing today it's all
downhill after that inter I'm afraid you
have the secret to happiness is low
expectations at least for me and our
guest today is the real draw and I'm so
excited to be speaking with them but
before we get to that let's just roll a
little sizzle reel that we have to whet
your appetite so AV guys if you could
roll the reel
[Music]
houston we have a problem find professor
Langdon give you somebody nobody
[Applause]
might make a hippo all was it good for
you I've had better
eyes soon who's in control they're
looking at a Red Planet I mean this
stuff has been really have you decided
accept that you're seriously flossing
don't forget to thank me baby don't
forget to thank your cookie
we are in the middle of a war one that's
been going on forever they talking about
you asked what would be worth killing
for me
witness the biggest cover-up in human
history
they can't get involved these people's
problems I don't think they're gonna
make it for not together to help our ma
agents so that they have a fighting
chance against the submachine guns are
some the most dangerous characters and a
history of American criminality
[Music]
it's a bigger idea than just the concert
we all have the same struggles
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
clear eyes for homes
[Music]
how biggest universe you can how do you
know for sure I don't I just believe
salmon's laughs I guess gentlemen it's
been a privilege fine with you aren't
saying that when the President does it
that means it's not
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so as some of you know I'm just a
professional dilettante who gets to
sometimes interview people who are a
world class of what they do and this is
certainly the case quick housekeeping
question for people backstage clocks is
55 minutes I could spend that much on
one movie I assume I have 90 minutes
head nod or no do we have clarity yes
okay great so let me do a little read
this is a rare rarely cited live
addition of the Tim Ferriss show so
thank you for coming so who is our guest
today Brian Grazer as you know is an
Academy Award and Emmy award-winning
producer whose films and television
shows have been nominated for 43 Oscars
and 187 Emmys just let that sink in for
a second there are people whose careers
are defined by being Emmy nominated one
time all right 187 his movies include a
beautiful mind Apollo 13 American
Gangster 8 mile Friday Night Lights
Parenthood and splash his television
shows included most recently genius
about Albert Einstein Empire 24
int'rested development grazer has been
named one of Time Magazine's 100 most
influential people in the world and his
book a curious mind subtitle the secret
to a bigger life is a near Times best
seller please welcome to the stage Brian
Grazer
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay here we are and here we are reusing
two sets of mics because as some of you
may know two is one and one is none
always have a backup so I thought so
many hundreds of ways we could start
this but I'm gonna go and use a
tried-and-true playbook the way that I
think all good interviews start is by
talking about four foot ten Jewish women
so could you could you please tell us
about your grandmother
okay grandmother I had a pretty normal
family or felt it actually it looked
like it was normal but but I did have
one in the entire family had one person
that was a champion of me that was a
believer and that was my grandma grandma
Sonya who I dedicated my book to and
should be dedicating everything to and
you really just need one believer she
was a tiny little feisty renegade named
Sonya she was about 410 and she would
watch me she I'd see her every week and
as a elementary school student she tell
me I was gonna be special I am special
and she meant in the best sense and I
would be looking at my report card and
it was all f's
everything was an F and there was a
point where I kind of thought there is
really no empirical data that supports
that I'm gonna be special but nothing to
find her nothing could where her dad I
just and so and and she was there also
an early supporter of
me asking questions and using curiosity
as a force or an engine to understand
things because and we spoke for only a
minute because I had was I was struck
with dyslexia and but it wasn't thought
of as dyslexia then it was just I was
just embarrassed too that I couldn't
answer questions and read books and you
sort of duck and hide so the dyslexia
you're clearly very smart and very
curious and we're gonna spend a lot of
time on curiosity but I'd like to before
we
to Brian Grazer in quotation marks to
talk about Brian Grazer the younger not
to be confused with the Roman of the
same name but it's easy to look at
people say on one of these stages and
assume that they're superheroes who have
just been hitting home runs with every
app that I want to talk about
specifically and I actually don't know
the full story but could you tell us
about your experience being cut from the
football team oh okay
so first of all I'm from Los Angeles and
from San Fernando Valley it's a flat
part the really okay so I went to
Chatsworth High School Nobel junior high
come on really
all right so all right so I'm at check
so first of all I was a very feisty kid
and I was a very resourceful and had a
lot of energy and we could keep up in
sports
with all of my friends in elementary
school and junior high when we
transitioned into high school all my
friends became six three or six four and
as you saw I'm my license says five
eight I'm not sure so in any event but I
thought I could play football and so I
went out I went out for football did
hell week which is like what it sounds
like hell week and I got through it and
the coaches said okay everybody in an
auditorium so there was about 300 kids
all in an auditorium and there were two
state that the job was your status your
name and your status
so it would be Steve Parrish elmire
tailback Richard Cox I'm giving you the
real names quarterback Brian Grazer
tailback incorrect everything stopped
and I he said after he said incorrect
coach Ogawa said cut so I got cut from
high school football in front of about
300 kids and it was pretty it was look
it was [ __ ]
momentarily or maybe a little longer
than that traumatizing because before I
had to get my stat name and status I was
a human being and once I did that I was
no longer a human being and certainly in
that room and it stuck with me and
that's that and but it stuck with me and
I retained the memory of those ten
seconds and if you want me to go it gave
life to when I read a book it was called
Friday night light and there's a lot of
weight everything is about all content I
think involves a unique perspective and
so my perspective on this book was sure
it's about small town a small town in
Odessa Texas and sure it's about what
small town living is like and it is
about high school football but it's also
about the fragility of what it's like to
grow up as a young boy 15 16 17 years
old and that a single moment like the
one I just had can be absolutely seismic
in somebody's life and can completely
redirect where you thought you were
going so I was it so that was my
connective tissue to this book called
Friday Night Lights and then I grabbed a
hold of it and I avenged him in the long
I gave a short story end of it I ended
up making it into a movie
but wasn't that simple of course and
then I ended up turning it into the TV
series that you guys probably know
Friday Night Lights did you share that
story of getting cut with people in your
family or your close friends did any of
them was it was any person in your life
able to help you repair that or was that
something that you did on your own uh
well that's a that's a shame issue so I
probably didn't share it no one's
actually asked me that question I said I
didn't really share that I shared it
once I made this movie and I was proud
of the movie but I didn't share at the
time no were there any role models or
coaches or teachers who acted as a
counterweight to that who
perhaps helped you or particularly
inspired you oh I had a coach
Wiley coach Wiley was a football coach
and kind of tough but he was also the
swim coach and I had this accident
experience of being incredibly good as a
hundred butterfly swimmer and it was the
oddest thing because I felt so badly
about myself because of the the football
that I went into I I went into track and
I did gymnastics but that wasn't very
satisfying I said well try something
else it's also a way to duck out a first
period so I went to swimming I went out
for swimming and the worst absolutely so
we had a pre-need of Los Angeles City
meet there's about 60 schools in Los
Angeles City and they go he goes grazer
Lane eight but I've never really swam
the butterfly I just kind of held the
side of the thing and I swam a little
bit like that freestyle and he goes Lane
eight butterfly like okay they kind of
become alert and I get in Lane eight and
Lane eight by the way let me tell you is
the worst Lane because you're getting
all the flow over and everything else
and you're kind of Bob and as you're
swimming and I I'm swimming this
butterfly that I hadn't really swam and
I hit the side of the end of the pool
and I thought everybody was out of the
pool and Wiley's there with a clock and
he goes you just broke the city record
and I'm going oh that's amazing and I
looked at everyone who's behind me and
he became my hero
because he then championed me my
grandmother could relay it off to coach
white now if I'm just imagining like the
mutant like shoulder mobility that
somehow granted you this gift but I'm
not gonna dwell on that it's my
understanding based on my homework is
that you dropped out of college yeah
whether you dropped out of school and
that teacher recommended that you do
that is that is that accurate or am I
reading the wrong vandalised page I
think that somewhere well it's in there
somewhere but it's more that as a
freshman in college there was a speech
oh boy this really actually parallels is
what's going on right now there's a
metric involved actually I was in speech
class and there's about 125 kids in this
freshman speech is this speech meaning
public speaking class public speaking
it's public speaking class and it was a
mr. French
sounds like a television name and an
event so mr. French says why don't you
stay behind so I stay behind he puts his
arm around me remember exactly what he
look like he said I want to make a
recommendation my recommendation is that
you discontinue going to college
I've been watching you you've been in
the class I really think that this is
kind of a it's you know like not futile
but a little bit of a waste of time for
everybody I thought about I though wow
what is this guy horrible so I didn't
quit college I I did stay in college
meant he was really pretty emphatic
about going to an occupational school
when she recommended what was the what
was the occupational school oh it was um
it's on Woodland Avenue but it was like
you're working with your head anything
to do it was like working with your
hands what effect like he would know you
know what would happen what effect would
affected that have on you that that
transition is well I patients right
through somehow got through that class I
got like a C or something and I I said I
did stay in college I graduated USC I
did pretty well actually because I
somehow found a system when the last two
years had a test you know just a system
of being able to synthesize and then
literally integrated into my system
right before I went to sleep at night so
I was able to assimilate it and actually
perform so it wasn't fully just
memorized it was assimilated what was
your system well the system was really
it just I would just continue to white
aggregate what was going on in the class
and by writing it down sorry by writing
by writing it down and reading books and
yellow penning stuff and and and then I
would just continue I was always editing
the system almost like a movie as I was
propelling myself through the class and
when it came to any big test
I was I was at a point where I had
synthesized it to something I could
really look at it in less than an hour
before I went to bed and I wasn't really
I mean now I would say it was a way it
did enter your subconsciousness and and
I was able to really do that really did
well but then I did discontinue going to
law school I think that's what you write
got it
yeah but why did you discontinue going
to law school I thought there'd be no
way I'd passed those tests why didn't
you go to law school well I didn't
really know what to do so when you
graduate college you kind of don't know
what to do I mean well you guys probably
I still don't know clearly know what to
do here
but I didn't know what to do so I
thought well you know one of these I'll
go to law school and so but okay so what
happened is I thought okay I thought
okay I get into law school and then I
over I mean living in an apartment
complex in Santa Monica and I overhear
these three guys that are all graduate
just had graduated law school and one of
them says yeah man I just left the
cushiest job and I'm thinking wow what
an interesting word cushy job I mustn't
mean really easy so I so I literally
opened up the screen the window and
closed the drapes so I could literally
listen in and he said yeah it was so
easy man we got it was a $5 on our job
and they gave us a company car I got a
company car and it was at Warner
Brothers in the legal department and
they said he said his name Peter connect
but I literally when they walked away I
just I got the number eight four three
six thousand just out for one one got
safe and I called and said I understand
you might be looking for a law clerk and
I'm preparing myself to go to law school
and I'd love to come in and meet and I
got the job that day so
[Applause]
so then that leads to a lot of other
stuff so basically then I now have the
job as the law clerk and literally it is
the crappiest little job as the
crappiest little job in the tiniest
little office with no windows I mean
it's literally had to it was like a
prison cell but I was in there and every
once in a while they'd say you got to
deliver papers to make named famous
people or powerful people the woman
named zoom ingress it was the head of
ICM that international creative
management and the most important agent
in the world you got to deliver these
papers and so pretty early on I had to
deliver some papers to Warren Beatty and
Warren Beatty was a giant movie star and
he's living at the Beverly Wilshire
hotel and had like a penthouse at giant
penthouse area and an assistant to an
assistant comes downstairs to say like
hand me the papers kid you know like
that kind of a thing and I say I think
why don't I say they're not valid unless
I get them to mr. Beatty my hand to his
[Music]
eye
I try that out and it kind of works and
another assistant comes down like we're
having trouble with this kid down here
you know like he says you have to hand
it in
so his number-one personal assistant
comes down I said look I'm just telling
you straight up these papers are invalid
once I hand them directly to mr. baby so
they go okay and so I go upstairs and I
now it's like I see this Adamas you know
weren't baby and I literally I go Panama
papers and I create a conversation right
away and I just by accident-- 'add into
like expanding that conversation until
like an hour of Kandra of talking and
the guide really dubbed me and I'm
thinking this is amazing I can do this
every time
so so I start doing it every time and I
get every person I get to go see the
author of the egg The Exorcist literally
I had to drive it out to Malibu and
before you knew it I got through the
butler and I'm sipping espressos on the
porch over the ocean I'm only 22 but but
I'm really learning a lot I'm feeling
like wow this is a great sort of
learning tool also I mean I'm also using
the Warner Brothers assets to advantage
me but I wasn't really hurting anybody I
wasn't stealing and so so that's that
sort of beginning of it and then I
discontinued going to law school and I
convinced my boss can I stay there for
one more year I'm pushing Law School a
year right
but so of just online this very quickly
so that we don't have to end quickly I
think this is fine so I realized that I
could actually use my own so then what
happens is sorry so then I see that
somebody a senior vice president of
business affairs got fired and has had
this giant office and it was vacant and
I say to my boss Peter connect who
started with Jack Warner in the day who
leaves like at lunch I say do you think
I could have that office you know then
he goes sure no problem
so I now have an office bigger than my
bosses and it's so far away from my boss
he doesn't even notice me really and
then but I'm right outside the cadre
about decision makers the chairman of
the board
Ted Ashley the vice chairman of the
board was John Kelly and then Frank
Wells okay so then they would go hey you
know like you seem like a good kid why
don't you sit on my couch and watch me
work and I thought wow this is great I'm
really learning a lot watching them work
hold on hold on I wasn't gonna interrupt
but I have to hit pause I've never had
that happen to me
how did it come to pass that they said
hey kid you seem like I would enjoy
having you sit on my couch watching me
work well I was a very annoying that but
just well in case I did have this tool
that I didn't really imagine to be the
superpower of curiosity but I had this
sort of bridge where I could ask
questions there was a huge circular
driveway that were the big shots could
park and I would find my way to sort of
beat down there when their parking their
car and I'd say hey and they'd walk got
him up would come on up with me and and
one of them took a real liking to me and
his office had no desk it was just I was
so admired the office had no desk it had
like a big like swordfish that he caught
boats and stuff but I'm thinking wow
this is the life this seems like the
right business but then what I did I had
two union secretaries and I can do this
quickly a - Union secretary don't do you
secretaries that they wouldn't fire and
they were really strict because they
didn't like that I was using the office
and - for me - been a benefit of me and
so they were like getting really mad at
me and they got my parking revoked and
stuff like that and and there had to be
a point well I started to use the office
every single day for a year I met a new
person that was getting something done
in the entertainment business from every
cent every chairman of every studio from
Mel Brooks to Richard Brooks I mean
stars and I would just I would call up I
know the speech so well hi my name is
Brian Grazer I work at Warner Brothers
pictures this is not associated with
studio business but I'd like to meet
your boss for the following reasons
and I might be like three or four tears
down I'm saying this - you know like you
know - one assistant to another citizen
and I can where everybody down
eventually and and then my assistant
said we're sort of sickie you we're
getting you fired I said okay hold on
before you fire me I will give you half
of my salary if you
get me fired so so they took half my
salary hold on
so just a few details so I can fill in
the gaps apologize to the audience of
the Long Island my brain doesn't move
very quickly so all right we're to begin
first what would some example reasons be
I want to meet your boss for the
following reasons
do you remember what types of reasons
would you cite okay okay that's a real
question okay I like to lead with my own
fake questions to warm you up for the
like okay well what I did learn to do on
the series I did learn to prepare so it
wasn't just like fly by the seat of my
pants
I really really prepared so first of all
by being in that office I would read the
trades and I just I decoded the language
of entertainment because the language of
show business is like it looks like hey
let's go to a party and hang out there's
a lot more than let's go to a party and
hang out and so I was able to like fly
my little Cessna through this fog and
find my way to understand beneath the
language I started to understand the
mechanics of how it worked and how to
actually we're leverage where the
leverage was so the leverage could be
the studio because they have money or it
could be creative leverage because a
director was expert at something or it
could be that you just had IP or it
could be that you create IP so I was
able to understand all the system of
leverage and so so I was able to I was
able to say to somebody I've I've
researched your boss I'd love to meet
him for the following reason and the
following reason like Robert Evans it
would be real reasons like I saw The
Godfather and I can't believe that he
could be was involved in the creation of
that plus love story they're so diverse
I mean I mean literally stuff like that
so I I was good at it and but it was a
little [ __ ] in it too but I was good
at with Lew Wasserman yes
so basically Lew Wasserman was the king
of the entire movie business he was that
patriarch
it all and here an Universal the
universal of movie and television
company and I'm thinking wow would I
like to meet Lew Wasserman he is the man
I'm gonna meet him and he was sort of
like the elderly statesman and he was
friends with Henry Kissinger I mean he
had it all because a man for all seasons
and so I I target a lot of his
assistants and I eventually met a melody
his number-one assistant in the parking
lot
way out um a lot and I said oh come on I
begged her anyway and she said okay so
uh so then what happens is I'm in the
elevator going up to now meet Lew
Wasserman press it up I get into the
elevator now I'm on the 14th floor I get
out he's got his hands in the air like
this like don't go any further so he
wasn't like any other normal guy I was
meeting he stopped me before I could get
into his office kind of like that look
of like you're just bullshitting me
and I sort of it was it look like I
didn't I couldn't say much I was sort of
frozen and he said wait one minute and
he goes into his office and he comes
back with a pencil and a legal tablet
and he said you put the pencil to the
paper and it has greater value than it
did as separate parts get out of here so
so I take the pencil of paper and I'm
now escort to the elevator and I thought
what is he saying what's going on here
and I realized what he's saying is like
you've got to do better than this you
better start writing ideas even if there
are little ideas that you can breathe
breathe life into or that have some have
value and did he say that at the
beginning of like being substantial did
he say that because he saw in a letter
some inkling of wanting to create your
own movies or was there something else
that led him to make that recommendation
or did or was it just a general lack of
substance that he saw and therefore he
said hey kid I love the part you might
have liked me
but a little tiny bit but mostly just
felt like let me give him some advice
and get him out of here some real advice
so I'm gonna back up just a second to
the half a salary thing yeah so in that
case you're you were offering happier
salary to an assistant who helped XYZ
powerful or well-known person to prevent
you from getting fired yeah there were
two a union once a paralegal and one was
a secretary that were there from the
previous boss and I was on your a lot or
near your Warner Brothers I see got it
yes okay on the Warner Brothers lot and
that those two secretaries of were there
in the office of the executive that I
then inhabited his off Isaac sorry no no
that makes it that day where was it
going hey you're like a scammer cut it
out and they they got my parking
stripped away so I had to park the
copper penny across the street and just
a bunch of stuff so the the the art and
craft of getting these meetings is
something I want to talk about and
you're very well known for these
curiosity conversations but do you
recall how you struck up a conversation
with Warren Betty because with who with
Warren early on with Warren bass
yeah because early on everyone I would
imagine during that period of time is
trying to do exactly the same thing so
do you recall at all the approach or
what you said that okay door well I have
a system now that's much more refined
because then it was then but at the time
heaven can wait was built on a move on a
material called mr. deed just comes to
town I believe and I should know this
but you ask good questions that's why
you've got you I think I think you've
checked the good factual recall box I
said do you explain to me like how mr.
deeds comes to town is gonna become my
heaven can wait in kind of a fantasy
like what is that gonna be because
that's for the pit the papers were mr.
deeds it was a it was being it was
they were all internal interlinked and
so I started off like that so I had a
prop props are very very very important
and you've refined it since yeah but I
do want to talk about the early days and
then we're gonna get to the current like
model of Lamborghini version of this but
my understanding and it could be also a
misunderstanding is that there was one
line in particular that you used quite a
bit that caught my attention at least
and it was along the lines of I
absolutely don't want a job but could I
please meet your boss so the the I
absolutely don't want a job where there
any other keys if that is actually
accurate that's a yes is it's accurate I
would say - and I still say I'm there's
not gonna be an ask I just want to have
a one-on-one conversation it can be a
very short conversation it's up to you
it's up to your boss whoever I'm
speaking to but they'll be you know
essentially there's you're never your
boss is not gonna be uncomfortable I'm
not gonna ask for anything I'm not gonna
position them I'm not gonna ask him one
of those really hard questions Barbara
Walters questions you know I'm not gonna
do any of that so basically you're
everybody's gonna be safe here mmm that
was the that was the premise and how did
you select because it seems like your
your curiosity conversations began with
industry insiders but expanded when did
it start expanding to people in the
sciences and in all different fields yes
for the year and a half it was just
completely in the population of
entertainment so big you know people are
getting something - principles that were
getting something done in movies or
television then I got fired clearly I'm
gonna get fired from that job right from
the Warner Brothers job I'm they are
they finally fired me
past when fire finally fired me what was
the what was the grievous offence the a
chart what was the camel that perked the
the camel's back that's it the camel the
[ __ ] that yeah yeah no I know that's
actually very easy to do the straw that
broke the camel's miss well I was doing
least curiosity conversations and I was
demanding to meet all those famous
people and but the straw was I started
to you I started to have I started
created tremendous access with myself
and their story Department the story
department had all the early submissions
of any script or manuscript that was
that could possibly be sold or bidded
upon or was owned by Warner Brothers and
so I was like crawling under the tent
and getting all that information and to
be really honest I think I actually
might have tried to kind of create a
fake bid on something and they just got
so annoyed with it at all you know it
was it was like that lecture of you know
we could you know file a lawsuit against
you but you're too young so just get out
of here a version of that see her fired
and I was like a fire but I wasn't
broken down because I was fired that I
thought wow I am really smart though I
thought I was so smart I thought I was
really cunning really resourceful and I
had researched a lot now and I've met a
lot of people and I started to
understand there's there's their process
their system of how do they would
accomplish something or just to keep it
simple and I thought wow I'm so smart I
should go from that fired law clerk to
being like running a movie company you
know surd but I did think so I thought
I'm gonna just jump from that guy that's
23 to like I should run somebody's movie
company well I found that that didn't
work at all
so I there then started getting
unemployment checks and that really
seals the deal where you know it's not
working she's getting an unemployment
check and then I thought you know what
I'll give myself a little more time and
try to pull this thing off just jump to
jump the ship you know like judge and so
I couldn't it did it didn't work it
didn't work so I thought you know what
I'm just gonna take a really crummy job
I'm gonna take a job like as the lowest
assistant and be happy with it like be
present in the process of the lowest job
which was kind of an epiphany but I well
it was an epiphany but I was also
reality so now I'm in the very lowest
job working for somebody his name was
Edgar Jay sherick Edgar Jay sherick was
Harvard and he was really smart and he
created the wild world of sports and I
ran ABC programming and now as his left
and and had this giant deal at Warner by
coincidentally a Warner Brothers
television but he also had money to
bring to it and everything else I take a
job working for Edgar Jay sherick as did
another a very esteemed producer exactly
at my level named Scott Rudin who I
really respect is a tremendous taste we
both were baby
assistants that called ourselves
lieutenants and then he was on the East
Coast I was on the west coast this boss
and he and rest may rest in peace it's
totally cool he was either yelling his
lungs out at you or giving you
opportunity so literally he was very
happy to scream at you and yell at you
and he could only be happier if other
people were there to watch it so and he
did that too Rudin and I but but he
wouldn't give you opportunity so all
those little stories I wrote a few of
them I was able to like sell working for
this bigger guy and so I sold two of
them and they became movies for
television when I was about 25 one was
called Zuma Beach she was just super
attractive people day in the life of the
beach but
but I would sort of say it's like
American Graffiti at the beach you know
he'll I give it a little dignity and
then I thought I can really be highbrow
and I think I'll do and I did I
I sold a 20 hour miniseries on the 10
commandments where each commandment was
used as an underlying theme in a
contemporary moral dilemma
and so I produced the Zuma Beach one my
boss was really embarrassed cuz he was a
Edgar Jay sherick but then when it got
good ratings it was like everything's
fine you know like it was good and then
I started doing the Ten Commandments and
that was good but he kept yelling at me
and it was really abusive and I started
getting a lot of job offer it's like
amazing opportunities and so I say to
him hey you think you'd give me a raise
no chance so then I took a job another I
mean a better much better thing when
were we on that subject okay I think
we're on all this up okay okay
oh and so from that point sorry
I know what we're talking about we're
talking about transitioning into more
broader curious yarn sting started to
gel and I wrote this I wrote splash
which became a movie you know a
real-life movie that starred Tom Hanks
and a mermaid and all that then I
started to say that I said to myself
there will be there will never be two
weeks that that I don't that i'm gonna
pledge myself I'm gonna create a
discipline that every sit two weeks I
will meet someone that is expert or
renowned or committed to something that
is unrelated to entertainment so science
medicine politics religion technology
all art forms and that's what I've done
still to this day and and without fail
ever and sometimes more than one person
every two weeks but always once every
two weeks how old were you roughly when
you made that commitment to yourself
well that exact commitment came at about
27 27 yeah and when did Ron Howard and
to the picture
how did Ron Howard come in Ron Howard
okay so Ron Howard came before night
shift and splash although I'd written
the story for a night shift and the
script for splash but I couldn't get
them to I couldn't get them made but I
still had this very big deal I had this
big deal at Paramount
because Michael Eisner and Barry Diller
spotted me and they said that guy that
this guy will give a raise to will
totally pay this guy he's like an idea
machine and so and so then I got this
job and then oh that was a time where I
wanted to meet people is still in the
business a little bit and I looked at
Ron Howard he was walking he was still
on happy days I actually yelled out the
window because I had a window and it's
really good building around Ron Howard
and like I scared him because he's shy
and now he's scared but I call his
office and I speak to his still now
assistant Louisa and I go come on
like done it I've done Itay the whole
story I know I'm on the lot he's on the
lot by my block and so then I get to
meet Ron Howard
Ron Howard literally it was the craziest
thing he hadn't directed of course a big
mainstream movie but he comes into my
office and I felt like it was it was
like he like had an aura of goodness
about him and I thought wow do I need
goodness so this will really be
something I need to ground myself as
goodness and I don't care if he hasn't
directed I'll get him to direct you know
like I'll figure it out and I also
wanted to be a mainstream movie producer
because I was produced I'd produce
television but not you know a theatrical
film and then he I go I'll back you man
that I didn't say man that would have
scared him too but but anyway so that's
how that happened and then the first
movie he wanted to make was night shift
because night shift was an r-rated
comedy that involved nudity and kind of
you know was irreverent and he was just
coming off happy days and of course Andy
of Mayberry and he wanted to go I don't
want to be that clean-cut guy anymore I
still might be that guy but I don't want
to be looked at as that guy I'm doing
the irreverent nude one with nude girls
and I'm not gonna do that one and so so
we got night shift made it wasn't a hit
but it was really solid and then I was
able to convince him to do splash and
that became a really big success for us
yeah okay yeah it's taking applause
break
this is my game to lose here at this
point no it's like don't [ __ ] it up
beerus alright pause
breathe Yoda you're doing alright thank
you
what advice would you give to people
would you recommend that everyone in
this room try to have their own versions
of curiosity conversations and if so
what advice would you give them how can
they cultivate that curiosity and
broader awareness and knowledge of the
world okay a couple of thoughts
one is I bet everybody in this audience
is curious so I because I know the
summit group and I you guys have gone
out of your way to come here for the
weekend and so I'm assuming that there
you guys are curious I mean the way to
maybe further refine it or to use it the
way I did ice of course I'd recommend it
because you gain you you get the value
of a different perspective that is
outside of the definition of what you
thought you're going to experience so
whatever whether it's an architect you
think you know what an architect is or I
thought I know what an architect was I
was wrong I met rim Coolhaus and the
first thing he said is it's like a live
architecture is like a living organism I
would have never guessed that he'd think
of architecture on its base level as a
living organism and I can go through
every one of my conversations where I
was completely described a surprise and
it either shattered a prejudice or
expanded a preconception and so
absolutely do it and I and and what it
does it sort of reaches right into the
soul of humanity which i think is
something an access point for all of us
I'm sure because at the very the very
minimally you're being really polite you
know you're asking somebody genuinely
with eye contact and caring you're
asking them what are you doing or how do
you feel you're you're getting into
something that's kind of real a minute
you're into some real place it becomes a
really powerful stuff perpetuating force
that leads to many other questions that
are really edifying
I definitely thinks that you should do
it and the other thing I would mean I'd
add if you if it to support it is you do
have to do homework it takes a lot of
case building and preparation so that
you're a good date my pledge was always
I'm gonna be a great date you know like
you know the the best date you ever had
with a guy or a girl whatever it is I'm
gonna be better than that with this
one-on-one conversation I'm gonna keep
it so they leave feeling like wow
something I got something out of it too
it has to be win-win and it can always
be win-win and these conversations
oddly enough each conversation was like
each individual lived inside of a was
like a dot living inside of a greater
constellation of dots and I just always
had faith that they may connect someday
and I found that many of them do connect
and form perspectives that are additive
in storytelling and then storytelling is
like a startup every one of these movies
I've made was nurtured out of from zero
and as was kind of a startup so so it
all kind of works together for people
who
for people who are excited to actually
give this a shot
and they sit down they find an
assistance or publicists contact
information on IMDb pro or wherever they
happen to be searching just in the case
of entertainment do you have any advice
for crafting say the email what are some
do's or do nots or specific lines that
you've found very helpful well you have
to start with an insight about the
person that doesn't it's not dull not
generic you can if your generic I'm also
teach I teach a the graduating class at
USC so after six years as one final
class and it's now called starting at
zero and I'm gonna do one session that's
if you get the chance to have 30-second
contact in a restaurant or a foot
basketball game you see that person you
want to meet how to not blow it and
generic questions always blow it the
other thing that always blows it is to
ask for information that you could get
yourself so anything you can search you
don't want to ask you never want to ask
in a conversation if you see somebody
how do I reach you it's the worst thing
because you figure out how to reach them
they don't want to stand there and have
while you type out their email they just
don't want to do that now so now in the
email I think it's once again you have
to say you have to connect your interest
and their interest and then have an
insight that lands in the middle and
you're gonna say give me an example it's
really hard alright what are what are
other ways to blow it then
are there other other ways to blow it
that you see a lot or now that you're in
a position where you're getting pitched
people want to have conversations and
objects with you okay
okay I'll accept that so
I will sometimes I'll give a speech or
have a conversation people go no I don't
wanna say it that way let me sit I will
say no I mean I've learned to say no I
don't like to say no because I'm a
pleaser but I've learned to say no
because often people just want to know
the shortcut
they might disguise the shortcut
question but it's they want to shortcut
like hey how do you be a producer like I
hate that question like I so mean gonna
say hey just crowd but or you know there
are there are things that that just
aren't comfortable for me like hey
there's no harm in asking well there is
a harm in asking
but I think if you have an insight you
see the movie dunker you get a chance to
meet the director for a second you don't
want to say how did you make dunker you
know you want to say the best thing is
if you saw it you can't pretend you
thought if you didn't and then you have
to say the unique trait about dunker
like the multiple perspectives of the
characters that made it's a subjective
experience or I mean I can just invent
stuff but at me right now but uh I don't
want to waste their time but but you
have to um the question was what the
question was
other ways that people blow it whether
they would J you were pitching other
people yeah but I think in tandem we can
come back to that well I have a son who
is just turning eighteen years old and I
don't want him to blow it so the other
day he he was thinking couple months ago
to go he will really wanted to go to
Tulane there's a bunch of schools that
are on the list but he think of Tulane
so now I'm at ask them to ID Aspen ideas
festival and I we see Walter Isaacson
who I did the Albert Einstein series
with and I go oh my god you're gonna
meet Walter Isaacson's Tom Thomas and
not only is he's this guy but he is the
key to Tulane he's on the boy he's so
he meets of Walter Isaacson just before
we go onstage and he's talking he goes
he's mine my name is ton he's a great
kid amazing kid says hey and they say
hello and then I look away because I
think things are going well he's looking
on his iPhone well write logic
Isaacson's right there that's not a good
move I don't think you're me you can't
be on your iPhone while you're trying to
have great connectivity that just
doesn't work so I say to him you're
gonna probably meet him again and sure
enough he did I said you and your pocket
have to have three things you could say
I don't care if he's talking about gucci
mane he isn't gonna go whose booty mane
you're gonna go like he's trapped your
knees gonna go what's trap then you're
gonna say it is mumble what's mumble its
trap you know like so you have to have
something to say or sporting you know
like you know of a LeBron LeBron got
traded oh did he really you have to say
something
how did the second conversation go oh
the second conversation went guess
better than the first but there's still
room for improvement how whether in the
early stages or now anywhere in between
do you choose the people to have lunch
with because you have nearly infinite
choice finite time how do you find the
people or filter the people to select
those you want to spend time with okay
well now it's almost a self-perpetuating
system but and people know I do this so
I have a trainer that works me out and
he goes Wow how did you see William
McRaven's commencement speech in Texas I
go no and so he shows it to me while I'm
on my elliptical and I go wow I better
meet William McRaven and then I get to
do that and that was amazing but how do
I do it I I you have to you go to blogs
you listen to cop podcasts and your case
and you go wow that be hip to meet this
person but I said that so casually you
you you
so that is there's so many ways to
stimulate an interest to create a pool
of possibilities I could also ask you
about a specific person then I think
you've met and yeah I have a related
question with Edward Teller oh yeah how
did you choose Edward Teller well okay
so Edward Teller was the thought to be
the fight of the father of the hydrogen
bomb and also was creating a Star Wars
program to protect the North American
continent at the time of the Reagan
presidency I believe and that was like
through missiles and webs and everything
else and I'm just wondering like if Jeff
Bezos is in the room because I did have
a chance to have a curiosity
conversation with him about 16 years ago
he blew my mind then and I still get to
be friends with them
I know he's speaking but he knows a lot
about Edward Teller much more than I do
so if you're here for that conversation
you might want to ask him but I did put
a lot of effort RAZR told me to ask it's
so but he doesn't know I know that he
knows quite quite a bit so um Edward
Teller took about two years to meet and
he said to me it took about two years
and I met him like with military
security around me right outside the LAX
like outside of LAX private Airport
because he had a lot of army guys and it
was like nearly a cavity search so I
could have this conversation and but he
he really really had no interest in me I
mean he had no interest really in
storytelling and I asked him what was
the last movie scene and he brought up
Walt Disney's animated film Dumbo and
not that that doesn't qualify as a movie
but it was quite a while ago so he just
wasn't really that interested but I was
I just kept going just kept going and
then remember Ron Howard and Tom Hanks I
had to go back to a meeting with them
they go how could you take it the dude
totally insulted you and I go yeah it
was kind of a bad experience I guess but
uh but I got a lot out of it so you get
a lot you can get gain a lot from
failure you learn a lot from failure I
learned a lot from the failure of
meeting Isaac Asimov which took a long
time to is a preeminent writer author of
science fiction and quite prolific but I
wasn't prepared well enough I forgot my
little coach ticket to fly like about
thirty five years ago to meet Isaac
Asimov and it turns out his wife game
who was actually also a psychiatrist and
I was talking at the Ritz Carlton bar
with them and that we're all drinking
non-alcoholic beverages and
she just looked at me and said let's go
and so they left after five minutes
after I flew there literally but I did
think didn't feel good felt like a big
waste of time
but it taught me to prepare hope I'm
prepared for this I think you're more
than prepared yeah
do you ever purposefully meet with
people you know you will disagree with
fundamentally yes I purposely do yes why
do you do that uh because it shakes me
up it wakes shakes me up wakes me up
also if you ever seen like just quickly
snap by just the fog of war by McNamara
I mean like that's the point of that you
you you don't have to like him but it
humanizes him through ultimately
entering in his perspective as to how
and why he became expressed why he was
what he was so I met Daryl gates who I
knew I wasn't gonna like he was the he
was one of the founders creators of SWAT
SWAT team police you know in forensics
and became the police chief of Los
Angeles and was right at the center of
the Rodney King riot and eventually got
was was quickly removed from office so
you know I do do that yes I've met many
cult leaders leaders of really very very
to say their names very intense cults
what did you take away from those
conversations how its well cult leaders
are kind of like in a way they sort of
operate the same way a dictator does
they they're very you know they're
seductive they're charming they're
cunning they're intelligent but they
have a belief system that they are going
to impregnate you with and
it's a it's an interesting study to
inhabit so you mentioned very briefly
and we don't have to spend a ton time on
it but I wanted to open the door at
least eye contact yes could you please
share some of your thoughts or beliefs
related to eye contact yes okay so I
just finished writing a book called eye
contact but it's born out of the it's
born out of the world of curiosity and I
didn't even really I mean my
appreciation for eye contact became kind
of retrospectively
came alive of the use of eye contact the
importance of eye contact the the it's a
tool that can't really be replicated
through anything and I don't think
through AI and it's a way to create
intimacy and Trust and you learn so much
through eye contact and I didn't realize
that it was so fundamental to all of my
curiosity conversations but it was only
about a year ago I had it was I had a
waiter that I go to a restaurant all the
time and the waiter said to my wife well
I really like Brian but he didn't really
know that I I didn't really think that
he couldn't know me well enough to like
me because I didn't think he knew me or
anything and he just said I like him yes
I like him because every time he speaks
to me he looks at me directly in the
eyes and it makes me feel like a human
being and I just thought about that I
thought wow it's really true I know
that's not deeply profound but it was
sort of deeply profound to me and I just
kept thinking about that and I thought
about how that worked in every one of
these
none of these curiosity conversations
would have happened they would have
vaporized or meltdown on the launch pad
if I didn't really have eye contact
because when you really have eye contact
and it's happening coming to life it is
again like a great date and it's the
best date and it
and I can't through eye contact it
becomes you know deeply neurological and
it's it's it's a very powerful and I
realized and then I thought back to
myself I thought well my partner Ron
Howard when I was really amped up and
everything like super amped up when
writers would come in and meet with us
just before the our first movie in 1982
a night shift he'd say you don't really
look at them in the eyes and I go well I
hurt everything they said I can repeat
it back but he goes yeah but it it's not
respectful and so I changed it sort of
temporarily but then I can all lost
touch and then I realized that you know
and then I then I animated it once once
again but he remember he said it to me
and it had a lot of impact in it you
know once again resonated but there are
times when you shouldn't have eye
contact by the way because I had a hat
there in tribal of cultures you should
look because I've had houses that I've
owned and tribal cultures and well done
you've had houses you found in tribal
cultures well I don't know let's go to
another question no I actually just did
not interrupt you please continue well
no the only thing I've been to basically
I had a house on the North Shore of a
walk because I like to serve and it's a
little tribal there it's it's very
hierarchical in this sort of tribal
sense and you don't you the word it you
don't look you're not supposed to look
people writing as you look at them in
the face to give them respect and just
divert your eyes just a bit because I
could produce negative consequence pick
your time in place so you mentioned back
when you were amped up yeah and I wanted
to ask the question how did your hair
style come to be as someone who no
longer has hair I'm curious
well it's converges upon a couple of
things one was
one was I I was a pretty successful
movie producer and I wanted to have an
identity beyond just because I saw that
the other there were other successful
movie producers like four or five of
them and they all had facial hair and
and I couldn't really grow facial hair
and so their beards were helping define
them a little bit and I sort of thought
I couldn't do that and then there was
one produce that like to throw stuff at
people and I didn't really want to do
that and so I I kinda was at a loss at
trying to you know trying to create an
impression beyond just being a producer
and I was swimming in my swimming pool
with my daughter at the time she was
like six and I just popped my hair up
and she like I left that so I thought
really so so we get out of the pool and
we go you know and I put some gel in my
hair
it wasn't my gel it was someone else's
gel put it in the hair and she goes
that's awesome that it and then that's
how it began and then and then just a
further a little bit so then I did it
and it was very very polarizing some
people thought a very small percentage
thought hey that's cool like maybe 20%
and 80% thought what a dick I could see
that they thought that and sometimes
they said it and I just thought wow it's
very it's polarizing begin it reveals
something it's like a litmus test so
then I just kept it going
so one of the things one of many that
has really impressed me when looking
back at your career is is how
persistently you have cultivated certain
projects and one in particular I'd love
to ask you about is eight-mile could you
tell us and I don't know the answer to
this but the how eight-mile came to be
okay
sure what I said no no I can't I can't I
can tell this to her
so the way well well I was dedicated to
having curiosity conversations had to be
I should really know but it was at least
20 years ago and I was in New York and I
was in a cab taxi cab and the cab driver
had on like a local radio show talk
radio show and old dirty bastard is
being interviewed by this radio this
this radio guy and more than 20 years
ago
so I'm going whoa this guy's choosing to
be called old dirty bastard that's his
choice he wants to be called that so
that already was interesting
so now I'm listening to ODB talk and I
want wow this dude doesn't even make any
sense
but he was so getting away with it
and committed to it I'm thinking I want
to meet him so I find a way to meet old
dirty bastard ODB and it was a trip
everything cost Mundt I mean I made I
met him he said meet me at a studio but
he wouldn't let me in the studio I was
on the sidewalk everything was like an
ala carte thing like if I wanted to go
in that would cost a little if I wanted
to watch him do something a little extra
it was bang bang bang was everything was
a it was all a card of you so I just
chose to stay on the sidewalk it's felt
a little felt like that's what I should
do and I just thought he is really
really interesting he's kind of funny
but he's also my god he's speaking some
truth about what's going on in the inner
city what's going on on the East Coast
and this in this music genre that was
you know rap early rap and so I started
thinking like what is early rap what's
going on that it up so then that led me
from ODB I think I'm gonna read meet
Slick Rick
now Slick Rick is really funny so he's a
guy a British dude wears a patch on his
eye and has to be carried in like this
like a king Slick Rick Rick the ruler so
I'm thinking so
so Slick Rick Derulo's really funny but
also cool then that got me from that
point I made Chuck D of Public Enemy and
that's another thing and I'm thinking
wow this is a really important movement
that's going on and while I'm in New
York cuz I do these missions like I'll
meet every in 48 hours I'll make a point
to meet every magazine editor like
literally of and sometimes newspaper
editors and so I can say this I think I
met well I met the most one of the more
accomplished newspaper editors Frank
rich Frank Rich was really credible
really really really smart and very high
quality and he said I said something to
him I met these guys that it uh and he
sort of dismissed it as an inferior
subculture and I said I don't think it's
a subculture I think it's the culture
and he sort of kind of you know blew
that off and I thought you know I'm
gonna try to like look at this kind of
is alike an equation that I'm gonna
prove in a story form like try to bring
some cinematic form to this equation and
prove that hip-hop is the culture the
pervasive culture not except culture and
much less an inferior subculture so I
went on this journey to try to do that
this learning journey that was more more
artists more people bah blah blah and I
wanted to capture the humor and the
truth and now I'm about eight years into
just doing this and I keep it alive and
I'm watching the VMAs that they're doing
in New York when the VMAs were super
cool and the camera pans and I see this
kid Eminem and the camera sort of sits
on him and he's got this I see I see
urban glare like I'm killing somebody
and then all of a sudden he becomes this
sort of fluid self effacing
guy that smiles and laughs and is really
elastic and I'm going wow what a range
so I'm thinking this is it really
interesting I want to meet that guy so
then I know I go to my friend long
I'm friend Jimmy Iovine who's like one
of the more most important music
producers ever really I think and who's
such a superstar for picking and he goes
yeah I can make it happen but it wasn't
easy to meet him and them but he said I
can arrange it you know he's kind of a
recluse but make it happen this is
before he really blew up make him a star
so he comes into my office in Beverly
Hills and he sits there like this and he
won't look at me I'm over here and I'm
like talking and I'm talking and he
won't talk back and I'm trying every
little trick and nothing's working it's
gotta be 30 or 40 minutes into this it
felt like three hours and he goes I'm
out I'm thinking here out beauty we
didn't get to talk you didn't talk so
I'm thinking I'm gonna have to beg him
somehow I have to find some way so I
used the word like he's at the door and
it I used the something like I don't
want to say it but it was like come on
you could animate or you can something
and then he turned at me and looked at
me like again like this is not a good
thing to happen to Brian Grazer
and but then he sat down and some one
thing led to the next and he told his
story which was amazing story which
became the basis of eight-mile and so he
was able to fully encapsulate what it
was and it was just a flashpoint moment
was able to grab this and he wasn't like
saying I want to start anything but I
could tell it was it because it
introduced what rap battles are which is
very cinematic and it was some it was
about and had a theme that I cared about
all of my movies that I care about begin
with a theme not a story because themes
are they're not challengeable love if I
may if love is a theme it's hard to
challenge that and say oh I I don't
believe in love you know or in his case
you know his that story was literally
like how does he gonna get through these
emotional injuries to become self
actualized enough to actually perform
and to be liberated from all of his
emotional injuries
he can look at the audience and say what
he said at the end of the movie which I
won't say in this audience but you know
so I thought this is amazing and then
why we were able to get him to do the
movie and he ended up of course being
the only rapper ever to win an Academy
Award and it was a great thing he's so
talented
[Applause]
so you just to follow up on a bookmark
from that so what you said to him to get
him to not leave was come on you can
animate or something along those lines
yeah I don't really want us I mean it
was something it was a little you don't
have to separate like that and but I had
to take my last shan't shop you know
he's at the door seems to have worked
out sorry I said it seemed to work it
seemed it worked it worked I could it
was like partially antagonized and maybe
I don't know work I don't know what
happened but he talked he I mean I have
the utmost respect because I've worked
with so many actors having produced a
you know similar around a hundred movies
and he was as the most professional I
mean he actually acted in every frame of
the movie wrote all of the music one or
not I mean I'll wrote all the music and
composed the music and and was a father
like and he he just don't get to see him
much but have the most respect for him
so we saw this sizzle reel earlier oh
and that was a pregnant comment but I I
I think that we could talk about and we
should and we have talked about some of
the successes do you have a favorite
failure meaning a failure that set you
up for later success or something that
was particularly helpful from the
standpoint of learning I have a lot of I
have a lot of failures I mean I do I
mean I'm fortunately I've had enough
good successes that that it sticks out
but I do have a lot of failures and I
failed different types of failures
sometimes when I violate my own rules
and I get lazy with my own rules about
choice of a movie where I get sloppy
about lazy in the choices of building
the foundation like any time you say
okay so I can sometimes I've picked a
director where I go he's good enough
because you're making a hundred decision
hundreds of decisions good enough equals
shitty
so that never good enough doesn't ever
work I do have one failure I mean I've
won you know a one failure of I produced
Apollo 13 and Ron Tom and I sort of
became kind of friend we were friends
and partners we all go well if we can
just make this good that's a win and
we're feeling so good about ourselves
because we're feeling like we're making
something good it's not gonna make very
much money but at least it'll be good
why want to make a lot of money because
everybody knew the end of the movie they
all lived with me like so I so then all
of a sudden we make the movie and that
movie does really well and we're all
really happy but then the studio goes
don't like a version of don't be too
happy let's see how it does overseas so
I'm realizing okay now I'm on this
journey I thought I was happy but now
I'm not happy no one's happy because it
didn't get released overseas yet so it
gets released oversea does really well
we have a few more of these things waits
like it's a home video ok so then all of
a sudden all the Platt financial
platform corridors are satisfied and it
does well then I don't even think like
this now the Oscars are coming about and
the Oscars they nominate there's like
five movies that get nominated and
Apollo 13 gets nominated for Best
Picture gets 9 Oscar nominations it
excludes Ron Howard which is was a super
bummer for him and a bummer no nuance
there just it was a bummer as well and
then so that was for him it was super it
was really terrible but now we're in the
Oscar race and everyone is saying Apollo
13s 100% gonna win
Las Vegas oddsmakers everybody's going
hey you're gonna win what are you gonna
say that it I go I don't know what I'm
gonna say I can't I don't know if I'm
gonna win I don't know anything I I've
already had like up and down like this
the entire time so now what happens is
it's the day of the Oscars and I've got
my speech in my pocket right in my
pockets I know I'm gonna be saying this
speech I know it because everybody said
it and in fact some very very famous
investment bankers one of them came to
my office I didn't know and
said I just want you to say a few words
about my pancreatic cancer company and I
got I can't
I don't can't think like this you're
jinxing me this is too much for me too
much pressure and so now it's the day of
the Oscars I got my tuxedo on I got the
thing and we're at the last award and
Sidney Poitier is gonna open the
envelope and he's very dignified and
he's a very deliberate communicator he
speaks slowly and the winner is and he's
got the envelope in his hand he's
ripping it open and it looks like he's
gonna say Brian I mean cuz I'm I'm
hypnotized I feel like a bee is coming
off his lip so I get up I won't walk I
get up and I walk all well very close to
him I'm up out of my seat and he said
Braveheart that's not Brian that's
another movie that's a whole other movie
so I have to turn around and walk back
to my seat Donna and I I walk backwards
because I'm so embarrassed and I walk
backwards
and this is so it's so vivid I mean this
got me on like taking sleeping pills
because it was so so when I turned
around one chairman of one studio goes
like this to me so I'm going oh this is
such a bad thing for me and and so I sit
down in a sweat and the real astronaut
that Tom Hanks played Jim Lovell is like
two seats down
he reaches way over Tom Hanks and Ron
Howard grabs my wrist and he said I
never made it to the moon either
[Applause]
so that's a hell of a story it's a long
story it isn't oh no one hell of a story
good that's good hell good not bad how
did that have
well actually did have a lasting impact
were you able to brush it off and oh so
well I mean it left okay what did I
learn I learn it what what I learned was
to certainly not to treat anything as a
reality until it becomes a reality and
that reality is a fluid experience and
that reality is always changing so
whatever data that they were supporting
those and win so basically you know
always stay down the middle lane I was
pretty good at that but I did fall out
on the lane I thought well I could win
and I'm gonna win and I'm gonna go up
but and then I eventually I did win for
a beautiful mind but so that was good
but be good but because I was in the
column of feeling like wow anything
could happen it could all go wrong I
like I couldn't almost couldn't talk on
that award I was like I went up I was so
nervous and I had this piece of paper
and I'm shaking with the paper and I
look at Russell Crowe and I say to the
audience I know that my nervous and this
seems imperceptible and they thought
that was kind of funny but then I
noticed like all of them most the
biggest female stars in the world were
in the front rows like sandy Bullock and
Nicole Kidman and every one of them and
I had known a lot of them from meetings
or working with them and they were all
looking at me like you can do this you
can do it because they could tell I was
crashing
[Music]
maybe it teaches you something about pre
anticipatory anxiety sounds like a good
answer I don't know yeah you mentioned
when you violate your rules for choosing
films or working on projects and one
that one of the facts one of the rules
being good enough is shitty can you tell
us about any of the other criteria that
you have for selecting or choosing the
movies I'm sucking and choosing the same
thing as well yeah yeah I start with a
theme and then I find a story that that
is compatible to that theme that
actually is a vehicle for that theme so
a beautiful mind I was just being
present looking around my world and I
would see people kids that were
stigmatized by even the mildest mental
disability and I felt shitty about it I
didn't and I you'd see is we can see out
in this area you see guys talking into
garbage cans and they're not just
talking into garbage can
they're mostly living in an alternate
reality and that alternate narrative is
the narrative of them talking into that
garbage can and it's not something to
you you don't you want to understand it
so that it doesn't it's not cruel or
stigmatizing and it took a very long
time to find a story that would be in
service of that theme but I did but you
you ultimately I mean ultimately I've
always said that I'm in the feelings
business that that it's not really I'm
not really as a storyteller I'm only in
the feelings business because if you can
ignite a feeling in cinematic form which
is an abbreviated way to connect right
go right into your bloodstream
then you've created some an indelible
experience for somebody that and if it's
that if it has hope because I try to
make movies I don't always win at this
but to make movies that have hope I
don't like unhappy I don't like to put a
negative energy out in the world they
don't but it doesn't have to be corny
like Eminem's ending
and coin didn't become you know it's
just or in in Friday Night Lights they
don't even win the game they just come
they just become more complete young men
and more mature and more and stronger so
so I think feelings are so central
they're the differentiator and if you
lose track of that I think you're really
lost it's very important when you create
any kind of story that your protagonist
is suited for the population or the
audience so you really don't want to
have a story that I don't want I want to
end on that it was well no I mean I
think well if you have a story that's
designed to have emotional impact as an
endpoint which is my goal you have to
think to yourself is that what is your
audience and make sure that the
characters that are personifying this
idea or the same age or likeness to your
audience because sometimes you can you
forget that and you go wow this is a
young person's idea and I have older
people as protagonists that often is
just a calibration is that is off it's a
calibration that's off I made a movie
that was to look at her time I made it
would be called fear fear starred mark
mark wahlberg commonly known as marking
mark at the time and Reese Witherspoon
and it was based on a lot of other
movies that mattered to me are based on
an experience like Friday night
something I experienced something
emotional or real that I'm able to
capture in a story or something I'm
observing so what happened is I have a
daughter her name is sage the one with
the hair who wanted my hair up so now
she's prior to that she's three and half
years old we're going skiing she burnt
doesn't really not a ski we're in the
chairlift and I go follow me as we
dismount she goes no you follow me this
is gonna be a nightmare
like this is what's gonna happen I'm
gonna be at three and a half she's
saying follower but sixteen I'll be
completely powerless
so I created a movie this thriller
called fear starring Mark Wahlberg and
Reese Witherspoon where she picks this
guide that is really charming and cool
and popular but really a psychopath but
the father is powerless and can't just
go hey your boyfriend's a psychopath yes
to be like hey you're really sure you
want to go out with them and you have to
really be think it through and so that
becomes this horrible this this
nightmare film that is a very very very
effective film unfortunately I picked I
lived it through the parents point of
view as opposed to the kids point of
view so it shows the points of view but
it's balanced through the perspective
and the and and the stakes are in the
man's the 45 year old man's brain if it
were in the kid's brain and what I made
150 million dollars but when I put it in
the wrong perspective even though was an
effective story personified through
through the parents it was it didn't do
very well at all but it was a good movie
but just didn't have commercial results
because it was a kids story represented
through adults so you have to actually
line all you have to calibrate all these
things and be very precise about it but
I can actually apply you know there's
like really by associative parts in
storytelling to any one of your
startup's I'm positive because I happen
to believe that everything is a story
I'm sure it's refutable but I think that
every everything is a story and when you
lose track of your story or the where
there's a company or human being you you
they create some misdirection thank you
for that
[Applause]
you don't have to worry about the time
I'll watch the time okay you definitely
don't worry about that you mentioned
good enough equaling shitty which I like
a lot what separates a good enough
producer or even a good producer from a
great producer in say feature films
taste tastes just taste having taste to
pick to pick the right subject to pick
the subject that is also authentic and
hasn't been inhabited from either at all
or or through the through a fresh
perspective so the taste in picking the
right thing the taste in executing
knowing what is good and not good it's
it's really completely qualitative you
know like what what some people thinks
is a good meal other person might not
think is a good meal if someone think
there are people that think that's a
great car and there are people that
don't think it's a great car so I I
would just think taste alignment and the
ability to execute it and so when you
build the foundational parts of what
whether it's your business or the
business that I'm in which is making
stories you have to pick people with
similar tastes and I always mean testing
that I always go well what does it look
like because I want the person to say
what they think the thing looks like
even if it's just a feeling so often I
do this little I used to do this little
trick of like I I would I could meet a
director that has very good credentials
of executing great taste but he might
not see you not be he might not want to
message the same thing that I want a
message so you really have to make sure
like so I would go like if I made a
comedy and I did this before many times
produced a comedy and I got this a plus
director and I go well god what would it
look like Ted and then they start
talking and and we're talking he starts
talking about wide-shots well I know
that's not right because comedy is a
close-up medium you know there's like
all these little giveaways that I'm sure
you guys will have within that you can
codify in your own
Festo so it's a very doable thing to
think through are there ways to
cultivate taste I still make mistakes by
the way I'm still very fallible as we
all are working progress is taste
something that you can cultivate are
there ways to cultivate it or is it more
like height or something like that it's
fixed yeah I think you can no I think
you can develop I think you can develop
taste it's just you just have to go on a
journey to do that you you would um and
thought of it but you would just have to
be exposed to the execution of good
taste in fashion and an art or in
medicine or in technology or do some
people see the uber picture in the game
and so you want to be exposed to those
people why are you laughing
Excel I like I think it's a good answer
it's not a mocking smile it's more than
I agree thank you no no no I mean some
people do they they they see these in an
elevated way and sometimes they're
accidents but you can you should make it
I tried to make this always part of my
journey but I mean Harold Ramis may he
rest in peace I adored him he wrote
Animal House and stripes and I met him
and he had such an I thought Animal
House was like one of the funniest
movies but he had a really brainy
Harvard brainy but I guess they don't
have to always be aligned but he had a
very brainy way of stating what that
movie was about and I thought well
that's really heavy you know like and
and so you know it when you hear it if
you're available to hear it but you can
create a discipline where you try to
sample stuff like why is Gucci good now
because of its new creative director who
picked it Pino picked them wide Pino
pick them
how does Pino pick directors I mean how
does that work you start going that way
I was so interested in your questions
that you could just ask questions all
day but last I was winding down we are
winding down the countdown clock
I've read and there are a lot of things
that are inaccurate on the internet but
that's you've said writing notes of
gratitude always strengthens me
I don't know Oh true but do you write
gratitude notes yes I have a gratitude
Journal that somebody gave to me a tech
tech Titan gave me what are you doing
any racing this gratitude journal so
every day he tries to address this piece
of paper we Veronica and I gave them
away at our wedding we had every person
got a gratitude journal and I try to
because I want to stay in my lane I
don't I don't want to enter someone
else's Lane in terms of light you know
there are life choices or their value
system or their economics or their lack
of economics I want to have compassion
but I want to be in my lane and being in
my lane I can have gratitude like thank
you for the help that I have right now
that animates my entire life my mind my
life my physicality so I want to be in
that zone well I think that's the
perfect place to wrap up at Brian Grazer
on all social media thank you so much
for a wonderful time ladies and
gentlemen Brian
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday and that provides a
little morsel of fun for the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in with your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by fresh
books man oh man do a lot of listeners
of this podcast and readers of mine love
fresh books to the extent that I ended
up meeting with the CEO not very long
ago why are they so popular well they
are the number one cloud accounting
software designed exclusively for
self-employed professionals that's many
of you and used by more than 10 million
people you can send invoices track your
time and get paid very very quickly
which suits the needs of a lot of
freelancers a lot of entrepreneurs and
beyond you can take pictures of receipts
you can link your credit cards and debit
cards so all the things you buy
automatically appear in your fresh books
in the right category so on and so forth
makes taxes easy makes invoices easy
makes your life easier
and also in fact I recommend a PDF they
didn't ask me to read this part by the
way they put another PDF a while back
called breaking the time barrier
subtitle how to unlock your true earning
potential so you can search for breaking
the time barrier a lot of people ask me
how can I get a 4-hour workweek with the
service business and the story in that
ebook its PDF is the short answer it's
really really good so I think you should
also check that out so breaking the time
error check it out but also why not test
out fresh books claim your 30-day
unrestricted free trial at fresh
ebooks.com forward slash tim and enter
tim ferriss two hours and two S's in the
how did you hear about us section that
sounds like we're gonna get very little
tracking that's a lot of work but just
go to fresh books comm forward slash tim
and try it out because it is a very good
product and i think you will find it
simplifies your life enjoy this episode
is brought to you by me undies i've
spent the last few years wearing
underwear from these guys 24/7 or close
to an outside of showers and sexy time
in swimming and they are the most
comfortable and colorful underwear i've
ever owned you should check out the
camouflage boxer briefs I'm a big fan me
undies are designed in LA and made from
sustainably sourced micro modown what's
that it is a fabric three times softer
than cotton trust me try it out you'll
understand why I wear these so much
if underwear isn't your thing though I
would imagine everyone wears underwear
but if it isn't your thing the undies
also makes socks their socks are spun
from premium material making them just
as comfortable as the underwear now
right now the undies has an exclusive
offer just for Tim Ferriss show
listeners you can get 20% off your first
order and free shipping so check it out
take a look some of them are pretty rad
they have different cereals from your
childhood on underwear and a lot more me
undies com forward slash Tim take a look
me undies com forward slash Tim they
offer a 100% satisfaction guarantee if
you're unhappy with your purchase for
any reason just send it back and you
receive a full refund again that's me
undies calm or we're
Tim for 20% off and free shipping
you
you